[Music]
hello my name is Sebastien vacuum with
the next series of Udacity talks and
this time we have a surprise for you
this time I am the victim I'm a good
friend David Silva who hits the Udacity
self-loving car program is the
interviewer he's gonna play the
Sebastien of this show
so David Sebastien I'd like to start by
just learning a little bit about
Sebastian what is the Sebastian Thrun
life story Oh God born raised and now 50
years old can you imagine I was born in
Germany I am I had a childhood where I
passionately disagree with all my
teachers and where I made a passion out
of trying to get through school without
doing homework assignments and I carried
this to college I drove my professors
completely nuts because I tend to
disagree or them on principle as well so
it was the most bizarre person that you
would want to have and certainly not a
person who would make it a Silicon
Valley in a character so honestly i'm i
was professor for about twenty or so
years and then i got a little bit bored
being professor I have to say because I
felt like I've done it been there then
became a mid-level manager Google and
eventually worked my way up to Google X
following the Google X and then
eventually I felt I've never started a
startup company I'm surrounded by all
these 20 old super genius people who
make companies like whatsapp
I got him do one and I've also felt I
got a change of an education at the
scale not just at Stanford but worldwide
so I I found a Udacity with some of my
students and Here I am alright so that
seems like a pretty modest description
of your life story you you started the
Google self-driving car project you were
tenured computer science professor at
Stanford and before that at carnegie
mellon started Udacity what is the
sebastian thrun secret sauce why have
you been able to accomplish so much boy
most of you take credit for other
people's work like yourself so you do
all the hard work and I take all the
credit that's what managers do if you
ask me like what's what's the right
attitude for life say
and and what's the right thing to do in
life I would say there's probably three
things that I could imagine right so mom
one is you have to have a curiosity you
have to a growth mindset you have to be
willing to try new things and and
winning so as you do new things willing
to admit failure admit learning and then
learn from it okay so a growth mindset a
second thing really important is great
okay great to me means that you willing
to carry through if you change your
thing every week and run away you're not
gonna run very far and then I think
that's the third thing is they have to
have visions you have to be able to
think big you have to be able to aim big
my good friend Larry Page keep saying if
you if you don't aim high it on shoot
high so I think you could be a pizza
pizza baker and work incredibly hard and
make pizza you're not going to change
the world the way in the pan overdue so
I think pick something that's really
fundamental like say qaul cancer for
example it's there's a big thinking or
doubt the world's GDP through online
education which is you'd ask this
mission so growth mindset grit and
vision that's the Sebastian Thrun secret
sauce boy as I mentioned I we take
fortify that he was working some other
people's work well people have much more
than I am okay
I'm flattered so so let's talk about the
latest step in your career you you
surprisingly use sort of stepped away
from self-driving cars in a way a few
years ago when when you have Google to
start you to a city why did you do that
and then how was your career progressed
since then when I was running Oleg's and
we not only did self in cars it was
incredible Google glass which has been
being revived for now which is great and
a product loon and many other great
projects and Udacity was an accident
III was also teaching in my free time
quote-unquote at Stanford and I was
announcing and teaching in AI class and
we took this class online and it
gathered a hundred sixty thousand
students what impressed me at the time
was and and today is that these students
were completely amazing like I always
thought the best students come to
Stanford but when we stack ranked
Stanford students with these online
students the top four never were twelve
students won't even at Stanford
and we'll profess me even more is when I
talk to those students I talked at some
point I sent out 40,000 emails
personalized emails saying you've fallen
behind in your homework and I got 40,000
excuses begged by the dog or but I'm
joking here but these were people who
were very different from you to because
tempers to never Mother's raising
children people in Afghanistan people of
880 or 12 year olds we had these kids
from Pakistan 11 years old who were both
competing to see you can do a better job
in the class they'd be later actually
invited the World Economic Forum in
Davos because they were so remarkable
kids and I felt that the impact I can
have on the world by bringing top-notch
education out of these Ivy League I with
towers the kind of situations into the
world was so much better
they almost fade in Mende that almost
took me over the the funny part is
honesty then when my students my
graduate students that simply asked me
like what is the right vehicle here for
me I would say don't worry you don't
pick your career your career picks you
and here was a seasoned individual
professor at Stanford Google eggs and
all of a sudden they're Udacity clear
just picked me
that's almost theological yeah a career
is a calling honestly one of my favorite
things to watch is Steve Jobs this
commencement speech at Stanford and I've
watched at least a dozen time and he in
his own language says the same thing he
says look if you're not satisfied move
on and I think he found his calling and
he had moments of despair like his more
and when he got fired from Apple but
Heinz that says I was painful to be five
Mabel but answer was the best thing in
my life it had have been unhappy there
before the rest of my life so much
better define my own career and why I
was not unhappy
yeah I can't I can't say I picked it up
I think it has he picked me hmm and what
about the latest step in your career so
you were the CEO of this company Kitty
Hawk how did Kitty Hawk call you I'd say
first of all I'm still very very
involved in audacity and I love being
here love being involved in viche I
found my brother so to speak and
overused to Amira my father for
different mother
my brother and we are incredibly close
and as a result I feel I feel as engaged
and and as committed to Udacity as ever
to be honest and and I hope that feels
the same way oh I mean yours clearly the
the leader of the company or the
visionary of the company we kind of
follow Sebastian's vision I'd say so the
the key hug experiment is about eight
years old and I've been involved since
its inception with my good friend Larry
and at some point I realized if I don't
help building up Kittyhawk the feeling
was I just need to do it I've always
been a roboticist enthusiast for
technology I've always loved to to
change transportation to be honest ever
since my high school friend died and I
just felt it was the right thing to do
so you work on flying cars now at Kitty
Hawk you are the father of the
self-driving car how to find cars and
self-driving cars compare our flying
cars basically self-driving cars that
happen to be up in the air
are they is there more of a distinction
than that your first I don't recall him
flying cars other people seem to call
them flying cars because they don't have
wheels I did they take off vertically
and then they fly I was on the land and
land vertically but they've the same
function as a car except it's in the air
and I believe that in the grand scheme
of things this kind of personalized
flight where every person can fly every
day will actually happen there doesn't
eliminate the self-driving car at all
because we still have lost my problems I
don't think I'm happy with something
like a helicopter or draw like thing
landing anywhere on the planet
because if there's lots of leaves
they're gonna go up in the air and my
eyes and so on there's a lot of
complications we have to figure out the
second thing I mention is we funny about
this and about three or four years ago
self-driving cars was not a topic I was
working in them I was convinced I drank
the kool-aid soda Larry and Sergey and
and and and Auschwitz and and my team at
Google back in the time but nobody else
did so I would walk to up to automotive
CEOs like Ford or Chrysler and they
would smile at me into any other way and
then something flipped all of a sudden
it became real maybe it was the larger
involvement of a larger community maybe
was the success we had or with
we team or maybe versus technology got
good enough for people and realize oh my
where this video and then a faith shift
within half a year Obama was talking
about it and dedicating money and all
the regular agencies were talking about
it all the car companies were talking
about all the tech comes to talking
about it I think in the vertical flight
area electric flight we are back where
was five years ago and self of
encouragement I tell people and work on
flying cars I can see the Smurfs in
their face and that is great so right
now very few serious player take this
topic seriously to be honest and I'm
pretty convinced it's gonna change the
next year too so in the self-driving car
industry that people are taking
seriously now how do you see that that
landscape you know it's it's grown up so
much since a few years ago when you and
Larry and Sergey were the only people
who drunk the kool-aid now what is it
what does it look like now how do you
view that world I think it's still very
very very early it's very very very
early no single company has yet
established a profitable business in
this space okay and as long I mean we
cook from technology side that is
certainly accelerating and I say that
the vamo team in particular has
accomplished an amazing feat in having
cars without people inside travel to
Arizona and doing so safely I would say
because this business have not been
established there's an enormous
opportunity
it's an estimated in the US every ninth
job that we transformed to the
technology
truck driver car drivers taxi drivers
but also all the secondary industry
manufacturers and even suppliers they
will all have to change and when that
happens massive amounts of money with
free believe in this face couldn't go
this way okay and like look at the small
things like toddler has really affected
trauma centers will be affected because
they would few in accidents and so on so
you're in big societal change and even
this happens there's amazing opportunity
to contribute and and also to be quite
frank to make some money what do you
think are some of the ways to contribute
and to make money in self-driving cars
what things do you think they'll change
about the world you talked about trauma
centers do you see other huge
opportunities where you see new business
models or
new value trends emerging from cloth
driven cars give you a simple one
almost all the working at now is the
United States and now China right if I
were to live in India I would bring that
technology to India and guess what
driving India is very very different the
rules in India are very different from
the rules the United States United
States the right of way is to be given
to the smallest did he like the
pedestrian in India my impression is if
you're the big guy one of the rules is
get out of the small guys get out of the
way for the big guys so this general
opportunity to build new technology for
a different market and then I would also
start thinking about like what is not
being covered today and so obviously the
self-driving taxi services we all
covered
the owner operated autopilot is is
covered even though many companies don't
have a solution yet but for example the
trucking industry has almost no coverage
right now
we had a start-up in the space there was
acquired by uber and now when you look
at this I think trucking is the most
frequent job title in many states in the
United States more frequent than
anything else so the market size in some
sense is much much larger interesting so
both international opportunities and
opportunities to to work on jobs that
people in all sorts of different states
have and help them improve the way that
they their work goes and I would say I
mean I look at a lot of startup
companies and my students do a lot of
startup companies and and and I often
asked like what you think about this and
and I often try to help people and I'm
often wrong to be precise but then I
would say we make creative what you need
is an idea that has two components like
one is you get to do we have to get to
the point even in the onset that people
can't live without what you're building
if you are a blind person today and you
have a self-driving car and gets you to
and from work say you will not be able
to live without it 100% okay I'm
convinced I can tell myself the story
and I'd be shocked if that wasn't the
case I think we tested it at Google and
Steve may in our blind passenger
couldn't live without it and the second
thing is actually really important is
take that idea mm-hmm like the blind
person can never doubt it ask yourself
drop the self-driving car is there any
better technology to give the blind
person the same experience maybe it's
videoconferencing maybe it's hell
popped us maybe it's implants and if you
then come back to the surviving car then
he ever good idea mm-hmm and I give an
example where I would not come back to
the self-driving car people now build
these sidewalk robots that deliver pizza
and I mean I ask myself like what's the
best pizza delivery I'm not yet at the
point where I think that if I wanted to
live Pizza the best way I would be
ground robots I might be flying robots
right and I might be wrong I mean
obviously the nice thing about Silicon
Valley is if you have many many
companies and some of the makers someone
don't and I don't have to touch them all
but if but what to look for myself I
would look for something where I could
guarantee to myself that the right
answer is the one I'm working on what's
your favorite type of pizza to have
delivered there's a beautiful new pizza
making a liver coming here Mountain View
called Zune which actually has like
saucy on the on the screen where the
pizza is at this point and the pizza
taste actually really good other than
that I love Italian pizza in Italy it's
unheard of it will need flying cars to
deliver that flying rockets I give the
pizza home so you all at Google when you
were at Google made the decision pretty
early on as I understand it to jump
straight to vehicles that eventually
would not have steering wheels that that
humans would simply be driven around
they wouldn't take over control of the
vehicle and one of the implications this
has is that the tests that way mo is now
running in Arizona are geofence that
they operate within specific geographic
areas and the vehicles don't travel
outside of those geographic areas what
do you see is the future of that on the
way to what sometimes called a level 5
vehicle a vehicle that can drive itself
anywhere that a human can drive how how
big is the gap between what's happening
now and and in that type of vehicle I'm
obviously not part of the Baylor team so
all I can do is look at my perspective
back in the Google days but Google
really believes that building this kind
of taxi service where people can lift
like or uber like or did he like summon
a car is the ultimate winning concept
for transportation because it's the only
one that can really cut on
transportation cost substantially over
other solutions
there's obviously I love and drive
and I love the autopilot but me having
an autopilot doesn't make my
transportation any cheaper all right but
but economics are really important I
think in understanding human life having
said this for me to be quite frank I
think what emerges to me is level five I
mean most of us drive in a limited area
anyhow so if I were to geofence the
United States and say Sebastian because
you know driving in Greenland
you're not level five I would reject
this so if this area is large enough
then I think be reaching this level five
and I honestly believe I'm super
impressed by way more especially what is
accomplished I've after after I left and
and in this specific pilot because to me
this is as close as it gets that's tough
because you can't take credit for them
after after you laughs well today the
team that I have following it the team
that I found and that subsequently ha
all right so so what are like what are
the big challenges between going from a
geofence in in an area of a city to a
geofence that's as big as the entire
United States now it's going to be
business right so first of all I don't
understand anymore the the complete
economics of this but you have to get to
the point where you are your service
that you're offering is substantially
cheaper than alternatives if you look at
an right sharing service my in my
calculation about two thirds give and
take of the Costas the driver in China
might be about a half depending on which
city operating in and so on so when you
then take out the right the driver you
get all kinds of headaches like you have
two engineers that fix your cars and all
you have to recovery crews when your car
breaks down and you have to put this all
together in a way that makes economic
sense and once it makes economic sense
it becomes in financing exercise right
like who's gonna buy a hundred thousand
cars right for this geographic region
over here how are they gonna finance it
how they face is in and that is a almost
like yeah it's just a straight financing
exercise interesting so in interview a
lot of the challenge of expanding the
geofence to a much much wider areas is a
Business and Economics issue I think
it's shifting there and if they ask me
like three four years earlier was said
look it's to the hard technological
problem it's certainly much less of a
regulatory issue today then I thought
three or five years ago so now really
becomes the race towards
a not just poor market fit which i think
is right to be easy in this case but
really building up a working that
balance sheet and a working business and
what about internationally so if we want
to take a you know a self-driving car
that works here in the US put it in the
United Kingdom is it as simple as
telling it drive on the left not on the
right or is there more to it than that
bins in the country right so I mentioned
India as an example I've been a number
of years agos in Egypt and also believe
Egypt had several different driving
rules then then I was used to from
Germany
I think the left-right swap UK and and
you know states that's not a
particularly hard thing all right I mean
obviously engineers have to go through
every line of code make sure it's
correct or a metric non-metric swap
seems not to be super hard but I think
as we as we go to these markets like
just came back from New Zealand and I
was stuck in sheep and the Sheep was
maybe I guess it is 20,000 I just want
to make sure I understand this you were
stuck in sheep like you were in a car
and they were just sheeps around in a
car and and it was I was sheep was
surrounding the vehicle and the Sheep
was going with me okay I was a bit like
a shark in a fish tank and it turned out
I was definitely he's half an hour in
this big colossal ocean of sheep and
other cars passed by me because they the
locals figured out if he got the exact
right speed and she just jumps away the
right way obviously we go too fast to
kill a sheep it's pretty a lot of
paperwork I hate this so I then started
driving a little faster and it got more
gutsy and I could witness the Sheep even
that I couldn't look back they felt my
presence as a car and jump to the right
way and it took me another 15 or 20
minutes to make it out of this that's
something honestly that's something I
don't I'd ever saw the United States
I've never seen that you know I was hit
either yeah
surviving and it's a big deal in New
Zealand because I mean there's tens of
minutes cheapest people I've never been
there but I'm excited to go get
surrounded by sheep and New Zealand oh
my facebook page you see the video I'll
go check it out everybody should go
check out Sebastian's Facebook page for
the video so what are the the big
challenges for people who want to make
an impact in self-driving cars and
flying cars what are the the fields that
they should focus on what are where the
jobs that are really
in these industries right now I mean
right now obviously engineering is a
huge deal so a very first chord I
remember self-driving cars even before
graduation we had a career fie affair
and half a dozen or so got an offer on
this spot right there is desperation in
the industry I can tell you and we are
now the pilot by far the largest big
education institutions so we are known
and accepted by the Mercedes and Ramos
and Tesla's and so on in the war which
it's great we have a fantastic list of
hiring partners so that's a no-brainer
my opinion but I think there's actually
opportunity beyond just engineering and
beyond the stuff we teach I think there
are strawberries in half airspace and
building cost-effective laser as an
example bidding better camera systems
and then there's more and more business
and strategy and public policy
opportunities in the space did vs
Udacity don't cover but I think people
should be able to enjoy I'm a Rybak I
did the math and looked at like
acquisition of start-up companies and
all these acquisitions that have seen a
talent acquisition none of them has run
me a running business and then I divided
the dollar figure by the number of
engineers and the number so stands it's
like 10 million u.s. ok ahead what do
you think about batteries is an area so
batteries an area really important for
flying cars how I mean how do batteries
work in the industry how important are
they for self-driving cars can you talk
a little bit about that it's super
important for everything everything now
it's battery-powered and we just begin
to stretch the surface of batteries so
for example I have a electric bike and I
love it all of a sudden I can go uphill
without sweating why is this shirt not
electric why doesn't it tell me when it
has to be washed and how old is why
doesn't tell me where is at any given
time when it gets washed too hot why
doesn't it tell me why didn't I have can
I rent this area over here advertisement
so I can make some money back so we look
at me you look at Google advertisement I
mean these I think that sound crazy my
shoes everywhere is bad we still parade
I think the entire world and almost
everything we all maybe battery-powered
and it's seen in bits and pieces coming
like your skateboard is not an electric
but we're just beginning all right I
want to want to close with kind of a
careers question one that may be
relevant to your own career um how do
you think about the distinction between
engineering and managed
so you have at different times in your
career I think been you know an engineer
writing code and at other times been a
manager and this is an area that's
growing very fast and many people who
get jobs in this area may get offered
opportunities and management early in
their careers how do you think about
that so I think of them as fundamentally
the same job I think an engineer takes a
physical artifact a piece of code piece
of hardware and figures out how to make
this thing do what you want it to do and
a manager takes human organization
people and figures out the way how to
make people what I want them to do
obviously so I can take the credit
jokingly the only difference is the laws
of physics and computer are very
repeatable mm-hmm and very
understandable a computer code in the
morning does the same as it could be or
an evening mm-hmm the the law of people
is more fuzzy and what people but
managers often often ascend to really
understand the law of people you have to
put your brain into the other side into
the side of the person you want to be on
your team do you want to be very empower
it's not about directing it's not about
commanding it's about empowerment if you
can empower a person that works with you
in the direction that you care about
then you get the same amazing benefits
and empower your computer problem to
give it a white coat or on the right
code interesting so you view them as
fundamentally similar or really even the
same job it's just in one realm you're
managing computers with computer code
and and the other you're managing people
yeah the only difference again is in
computer code I can tell the computer
what I want to do and its program in a
way that just does it and people I've
yet find to have to find a single person
who works in me I will just tell what to
do and people I have to win their hearts
and their minds and when people
understand that the mechanism different
then everything else becomes the same
it's almost like the different business
skiing and snowboarding there's actually
not a be difference once you understand
that the physical prints are the same
but if you feel it's very different in
the beginning so I I would any manager
listening to this I would say hey think
of it your own best finish I ever did
for you and then tip the answer is oh
that person empowered me how to resolve
problems and stayed out of my way let's
say do exactly the same for your people
and they're gonna trust you okay all
right that's a great way to think about
it so we have
a few student questions actually a lot
of student questions but I'm gonna pick
just a few so so one question I think
you will have a really interesting
opinion on is from Abhinav in San
Francisco and he says I would like to
try out algorithms on a real world robot
how do I get started so you had this
problem first at Carnegie Mellon and
then it Stanford and then even at Google
how did you deal with this problem man
your life is so much better than my life
my very first world would cost about
$60,000 and I had to convince my
department chair to spend that money
today you can go to Amazon and buy a 20
30 50 dollar device that you can program
easily I'd say just do that obviously
Udacity we have robots that you can
probably came from not afford really you
have this wonderful collaboration cuoco
vivek involve program robot arm we have
a self-driving car you can program here
until soon the surface is cool I invite
you over come visit us
I love to meet you in person but I think
the the interesting thing is people you
can by drawing signal program today and
then fly through your house you can buy
a robot second row me corridor the hard
part is you know what just do it okay
perfectionism is the enemy of the good
if you want to be the perfect robot that
becomes the successful startup and day
one you're not gonna succeed but even an
excellent experience make your robot go
from your bathroom to a kitchen
start with going from the bathroom to
the kitchen and build up from there and
if you do this any student here send a
video to th ru n at Udacity to come and
I'm gonna reply to you you heard it here
send it to through 'not udacity.com same
email address i use so colette in
georgia has a bunch of different
questions about safety will self driving
cars prevent DUIs will they be safer
than human driven cars had we get them
safer than human driven cars what do you
think about safety in self-driving I'm
completely convinced they will be safer
than humans in fact it'd be very very
safe and here's here's the reason why no
matter where you think they are today
whether they're safer than two people or
not the learning speed of serfdom in
cars exceeds the way people can get
better like when you and I say both make
have an accident mmm-hmm the individual
learn from it but I in O'Conner a few
accidents and you are not going for mine
so there's a lot
repetition so evidence around their own
mm-hmm when a self-driving car back in
the day google says I think I had an
accident or maybe they made a mistake
then it would learn from the mistake and
so would learn all the other cars
including all the unborn cars that means
it's almost like if we translate this
learning cable back to people like I
have a PhD but my son doesn't wouldn't
be great if my son was born with a PhD
right says something that computers have
over us and they're better than us and
that means no matter how skeptic you are
there will be a time when the learning
curve for the capability of the self
Levin carved cross set off the human
driving capability and will happen in
hybrid driving it has already happened
in my opinion and it's gonna happen
instance street driving as well
and what about flying cars that's a
little bit of a different safety problem
right a crash and a flying car seems it
was it superficially more traumatic than
a flat a crash and a in a car that's
already on the ground how do you think
about that problem I think I mean
obviously in my opinion flying cars are
much much easier to make safe than then
ground cars interest almost anything
that he would hit from pedestrians and
kids and so on and trees is on the
ground hmm he has completely free and
Diaz also huge is amazingly large so in
the ground when you when you know I
Drive in different directions on the
right with the same location same time
we have a conflict when your traffic
light or we might even collide
occasionally right but in the air you
can separate things in order to just do
this and and that freedom that we have
up there the only thing we have to
prevent is that these things fought with
from the sky but if you look at today's
air traffic just recently Southwest
Ellen I had an issue and a lady died and
I here was the first commercial death
United States in almost a decade right
right right yeah it's in some ways it's
hard to improve on on air traffic and in
air safety in the US right now because
it already is so safe but it amazes
people off of the ground then at least
you're getting them out of cars that are
crashing a lot on the ground so I copied
you convinced that it'd be safe idea
hundred percent it's just not today
obviously but it's gonna cost gonna
happen we have a question from Alexander
in Germany about the difference between
deep learning and robotics approaches
for self-driving cars and in particular
this notion of in the end learning
training the whole car to drive with
just a deep neural network
you you came up in the robotics world of
self-driving cars really before you
started your career before deep learning
took off the way it's taken off in the
last five years how do you view those
differences I'm completely blown away by
what deep learning has accomplished in
last two or three years and and I've
ever regret I would have put much more
deep learning into my project back at
cougar than I actually did we did a very
geometric thing we had this beautiful
hundred thousand what about a laser that
we could put on the roof and it give us
his beautiful plant point clouds and and
we've tell in love with those palm
clouds the type of Grand Challenge in
fact in the DARPA Grand Challenge all
the team not doing lasers end up doing
lasers and he's the winning teams and
and we stayed there so we have this
beautiful geometric reasoning mechanism
this fan I was on a team still I don't
know why it's now but then I look at the
successes of Udacity students doing deep
learning and a voyage and all these
wonderful things there's a complete
phase shift and I think this not just me
is the entire academia all the
professor's are realizing oh my god like
a classic Ivana's image object
recognition images seen at scene
understanding in computer vision it was
known up to about three or four years
ago that computers were much much much
worse in understanding and describing a
scene in people were like much were
substantially worse and then all of a
sudden they better now then literally
better than people so if you do a test
and blind test if the computer looking
at a hundred scenes and fifty people
look behind of scenes and compute the
average error rate machines just beat us
that's one of the things I really love
about working with you is how excited
you are about new technology you're not
necessarily stuck on you know what
worked for you a few years ago you just
very excited about you think about this
I mean the humanity is what I mean
people have made fire 300,000 years ago
I'd and we have almost everything that
matters to us today is invented last 150
years
I mean the stuff that's older maybe the
book is labeled older and the wheel is
older but even basic things like running
water and water toilets right and
electricity and the telephone and the
radio and airplanes and cars and the
smart phone and social networks it's all
like in the last 150 years and and why
is that because we freed ourselves from
the physical fieldwork that we did
before and we became more creative more
intellectual to me is
one thing I'm bummed about I would love
to live a hundred years from now because
there is so much more amazing stuff
happening right I think 150 years from
now you can build a company like Udacity
in a day absolutely
and that means we only charge one cent
to each student all right that's gonna
happen today is still a lot of walked
about all this stuff and in the past
where the universities international in
every country was impossible like we're
the front of the first universities over
in every country so I think it's going
to be so amazing see what's going
forward I wish I was like 10 years again
old again and we could could revive the
entire face today oh man I wish I were
10 years old again to that that seems
like a good note to close on the future
is bright and hopefully it always will
be brightened very much Sebastian Thrun
thank you David you're great I love you
and I love your team thank you very much
[Music]
you